after I recently told the story I don't
remember if it was on the regular show
during a call or the bonus show talking
about my trip to London but anyway I
told the story of how i incorrectly
thought that the europe power adapter i
had would work in the UK but it didn't
and i wasn't sure if it was as a goof or
not and now i realized that it's not i
was sent the world travel power plug
adapter with dual USB charger for review
which is available on amazon and it's a
really cool product and now i'm not
going to have these issues when i travel
to not just the UK but over 150
different countries and this is a really
cool adapter because number one it's
basically all of the adapters built into
one and now i don't even have to sit
there and think about okay well so is
the UK adapter the same one as europe
and what about Northern Europe vs
southern Europe or whatever the case
maybe this is one unit that weighs under
five ounces it measures two by two by
two and a half inches and as I mentioned
works in the US Canada Europe Middle
East South America Asia over 150
countries that this works in and one of
the other really good features that it
has is not only can you plug devices
into it with American items you can
actually use items from other countries
and then plug those in in other
countries that you may be traveling in
and it has USB plugs this is great I
know that oftentimes another issue I've
had when I'm traveling with my power
adapters is my USB devices that are
plugged into an American adapter that
goes USB to American wall power and then
into the foreign adapter it just doesn't
work so with this adapter you can
actually plug in the USB cable directly
to the adapter so needless to say i am
going to be traveling with this I now
I'm not going to need that entire bag of
adapters and turns out last trip I
brought the entire bag and still didn't
have the right one check out the product
I like it link is in the description